Barrett: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
I know it's getting late
in the day.
After all the hallway
conversations
and the other talks
you've been too,
you start running out
of steam, so I appreciate it.
My name's Ryan Barrett.
I'm one of the co-founders
of Google App Engine
and I'm the lead
on the datastore right now.
I'm here to talk
about multihoming.
So running a service
from multiple datacenters.
This is the kind of thing
we do over the weekend
when we get bored and,
you know,
we don't have
any parties to go to.
So figured, you know,
we'd hacked this together
last weekend and, you know,
I'd give you a quick demo.
So we're gonna
be taking questions
using Google Moderator.
And so if you go to this URL,
code.google.
com/events/io/questions,
go to the App Engine track
and the transactions
across datacenters series
and feel free to type in
questions, vote on questions,
all that good stuff.
So let's get started.
Let's start
with a couple quotes.
One is from a guy named
Eric Brewer,
who is a professor,
a computer science professor.
He's also done architecture
at Berkeley.
He's also a co-founder
of Inktomi,
which you might have heard of.
He's well-known
for this theorem,
the consistency, availability,
partition tolerance theorem.
And so the idea is
if you have
a distributed storage system,
this is just
an inherent trade-off that
you can't get away from
and so you better acknowledge
it early and pay attention.
It's not black and white.
You don't just
get two out of three.
Often you can get a little on
one and a little better
in another,
but this is something
we pay attention to.
He's also a wicked-smart guy.
The other one is not as
interesting, but, you know,
there is no free lunch.
Making some scalable
is just plain hard.
You can use a bunch of different
technologies.
You can use a bunch
of different techniques
and they get you a long way,
but you can't
just stick your head in the sand
and ignore it altogether.
You got to pay
a little attention
and so this
is what we've done.
So before I get started,
one of the best pieces of advice
I ever heard about presenting
is that whenever
you switch slides,
what everyone does
is stops listening,
reads through the slide,
then turns back to you
and starts listening again.
So what I want you all to do
is whenever I switch slides,
turn away from me,
look at a screen,
then when you're about done,
turn back to me
and I'll actually know
that I can start talking.
I know this is what I do.
If I'm not on my laptop
at a talk, this is what I do.
So anyway.
Multihoming,
like I talked about,
serving something
from multiple datacenters.
Hard problem, but we need
to figure out how to do it.
There are a lot
of parts of this
and I'm not gonna
get into most of them.
Actually running
a serving stack.
Most of the stack,
for example.
Offline data processing,
batch processing,
map reduce, long-running,
you know, data mining analysis.
That kind of thing.
Read-only data.
Content distribution networks.
CDNs like Akamai.
All these things
are really interesting
problems in their own right
and I only have an hour
and, you know, I even have more
than I can fit in an hour,
so I'm gonna stick with
what I've been working on
the last few years.
Well, for a while now.
It's what we call
structured data.
User data.
Data that is both written
and read,
often by your users,
and when they take actions
that write data,
they often expect to see
the results of those writes
and expect some guarantees
on consistency and availability
and that kind of thing.
So in my humble opinion
or the biased view,
this is one of the hardest
kinds of data
to run a data storage system
across datacenters.
So we're gonna talk about
a little ways--
a few ways of doing this.
How App Engine currently does
it in some places.
And kind of throughout,
I'm gonna talk about
the App Engine datastore and,
you know,
what the choices were we made.
Things we went with,
things we didn't go with
to run across multiple
datacenters.
Again, as a disclaimer,
there are a lot
of great talks at this
conference on best practices
for how to write
an App Engine app,
new features, you know,
that kind of thing.
And this is not one of those.
I will be talking a little bit
about App Engine,
but mostly just
how we did things.
Mostly it's just gonna be
general lessons learned,
both good and bad.
So I would encourage you
to go to some
of those other talks too.
This is more just
kind of stories.
So specifically what
are we gonna talk about?
First thing is consistency.
What kinds of guarantees
do you have
from a cloud data system,
you know?
How are they similar
and different from
databases and other
data storage systems
you might be familiar with.
Transactions, specifically.
What are they apart from
consistency?
Why do you need them?
How do they interact
with multihoming?
Why do we need to do
multihoming at all?
I mean, can't we just serve out
of one datacenter?
Then we're gonna actually
get into the details.
Talk about specific kinds
of multihoming,
specific techniques
that you can use,
and finally,
some conclusions.
So there are three kinds
of consistency
I'm gonna talk about.
There are more.
If you were
in Dan Wilkerson's talk
on distributed transactions,
you heard about causal--
Sorry.
Cause of consistency
and a few others,
but here we're mainly
gonna focus
on what we call weak, eventual,
and strong consistency.
And as a concrete example
for each of these,
we're gonna look at what happens
when you do a read.
When you read an object
after you wrote it.
So the first one we're gonna
look at is weak consistency
and this is the most text
I've had in a slide so far,
so please look
at the slides and read
and when you're done,
let me know.
Weak consistency
is what you get from caches.
That's the best way
to think of it.
You don't really have
any guarantees.
You put something in.
Later, you ask for it.
It might be there.
It might not.
You might never get it after
you ask for it.
You know, the cache just might
be churning so much
that things
are constantly evicted.
This is what
we call best effort.
I think of it as
"message in a bottle."
The memcache API
in App Engine,
it's just a simple
kind of unified
large-scale in-memory
cache system
is a perfect example of this.
VoIP and kind of online
streaming media
are great examples,
because often,
if you lose connectivity
and you miss some messages
or they come in delayed,
often, you don't care.
If you're talking on the phone
and there was a hiccup,
you don't want it to try
to catch up and get behind.
You still just want that
real-time communication
and so you're okay with it
dropping some packets
and so some writes
or some messages
that came from the other side
never get to you.
But that's okay 'cause
that's the use case.
That's what you expect.
Low-latency multiplayer games.
So first-person shooters,
that kind of thing.
Stuff that you play online
often are the same.
Sometimes you interpolate.
Sometimes if you just
have old state,
you don't really care about
where the other guy was,
you know, 30 seconds ago.
You care about
where they are now.
So there are many cases where
weak consistency is good.
It's the right trade-off.
But for data storage systems,
stuff that's persistent,
it's weak.
Eventual consistency
is better.
So there are great examples
of this.
The idea is you'll eventually
see the stuff you wrote.
You just might not
see it right away.
The email sending API
in App Engine
and email in general--
SMTP for mail delivery is
a great example of this
where you send an email,
you accept that
it's not guaranteed
to immediately show up
in the other person's inbox
as soon as it returns
from that send operation,
but you know it will
get there eventually.
The Postal Service, despite
their budget woes right now,
same kind of thing.
DNS, domain name propagation,
changes to that, similar.
There's some notable
cloud platforms.
Amazon's S3 and SimpleDB,
also SimpleQ service
are eventually
consistent systems.
So if you write a file into S3
or you write a record
into SimpleDB,
you won't immediately see it,
but you will see it
soon after.
So in SimpleDB,
I think in practice,
you see the results of writes
in a few hundred milliseconds.
I think they average around
400 or 500 milliseconds,
sometimes up to a few seconds.
S3 I'm not sure about.
But this is much more useful.
It's not ideal though.
The ideal kind of consistency
for a read-write
or structured data system
is strong consistency.
You get what you put in.
This is the simplest one
to think about
and to program against,
and again,
in my humble,
biased opinion.
So you're guaranteed when,
you know,
after you do a write and it
returns successfully--
it doesn't throw an exception--
any read after that
will see it.
The App Engine datastore
works this way.
File systems almost always work
this way.
Relational databases.
Microsoft Azure.
Not enough people talk
about Microsoft Azure.
I think it's actually
fascinating.
They've made a number of really,
really interesting
and compelling design decisions.
They're a competitor
to SimpleDB
and the App Engine datastore
is called Tables.
They are also
strongly consistent.
So these are three forms
of consistency,
weak, eventual, and strong,
that depending on how we build
a storage system, we're gonna
see one or more of these.
And we want to pay attention
once we try to move
a system like this across
datacenters.
You know, do we get
the same guarantees?
Have we lost some guarantee?
Sometimes it's okay to lose some
of those guarantees,
but you want to know.
So that's consistency.
Next is transactions.
And for those of you who were
in Dan Wilkerson's talk,
feel free to go to sleep
for five minutes
and I'll wake you up
when we're done.
Transactions are kind of an
extended form of consistency
across multiple operations.
The cliched example is a bank.
You need to transfer money
from "A" to "B,"
or as in Dan's talk,
from "Alice" to "Bob."
There are two separate
operations here.
Subtracting money from "A."
Adding money to "B."
Since we work with computers
and within a single thread
on a single machine,
operations are serialized.
You can't do those
at the same time
and something bad
could happen in between.
Something else could come in
and read from "A" or "B"
or write to "A" or "B."
The thread in the machine
that you're running
this transaction in could die
for any number of reasons.
On App Engine, maybe you hit
the deadline
or request deadline.
There are a number
of other possibilities.
You don't want to be
in that position.
You want some guarantees that
if you die in the middle,
the invariants
will be maintained.
Either that money subtracted
from "A" will go back to "A,"
or the money added to "B" will
eventually still
get added to "B,"
because as Dan said,
this case where, you know,
you've created money
or destroyed money,
you're not really allowed
to do that.
Only the Federal Reserve
is actually allowed
to do that kind of thing
and we're not trying
to get in the business
of banking.
We just write software
and we like it there
and we want to stay that way,
so we like our transactions
to be transactional.
So this is just a more abstract
of saying all of that.
Transactions give you
broader consistency,
correctness,
enforcing invariants,
and there are four
traditional properties
that people describe.
Transactions are atomic,
consistent,
isolated, and durable.
And any database textbook will
go into details here.
But these are nice properties
of transactions
and just like consistency,
they're hard enough
when you're operating
on one machine
or on a few machines inside
a datacenter.
When you start operating
across datacenters,
again, you want
to pay attention
to what could happen
to transactional guarantees
that you had before you started
spreading out
all of your work.
So...I've talked
about consistency.
I've talked about transactions.
Now let's get into the more
interesting background.
Running one datacenter
is hard enough usually.
Why would you want
to run more than one?
So there are some
good reasons.
Catastrophic failures are,
you know, the thing
no one really wants
to think about.
But what if your datacenter
fell into the ocean?
More realistically,
what if there was a fire,
which does happen?
What if the power went out
for a couple hours?
Which is not quite
as violent--
you probably won't lose any
data, for example--
but you're down.
You know, it's no fun.
There are also a number
of expected failures.
So there's hardware
that kind of operates
at the entire datacenter
level in the NOC.
The network operations center,
for example,
there are lots
of big iron routers.
There's the power,
as we talked about,
there's cooling,
there's backbone connectivity
in and out.
Any of these things,
they're usually up for--
they have good uptime,
but nothing lasts forever.
And so the more hardware
you're operating with
in a datacenter,
the more likely it is
that at any one time something's
going to fail.
So you don't like it
but you expect it.
One of the things you do
to prevent that
is routine maintenance.
But the problem with
maintenance, again,
is it takes some piece of
software off
or some piece
of hardware offline.
Finally, we call Geolocality.
It's a big word for putting
stuff near your users
so their requests get
to it and back fast.
We like this.
In the U.S.,
we are somewhat spoiled
and it's easy to ignore
the benefits of geolocality,
because lots of stuff
is here.
And we have good backbone
connectivity to everywhere else.
If you've ever spent time
in China or India,
there is kind of
a mixed bag in terms
of network infrastructure
at best.
If you've ever spent time
in Australia,
good network infrastructure,
but it's just far away.
You really start hitting
speed-of-light constraints.
How long does it take even
without routers?
Routing delays
or queuing delays.
Just that speed of light
to get a packet
from Australia to the U.S.
and back is a while.
I don't know that number off
the top of my head,
but I know a roundtrip from
the west coast of the U.S.
to the east coast of the U.S.
is 30 milliseconds
and that's purely
speed of light.
No routing and queuing.
And if you go through some
of the big peering points,
PAIX-East, PAIX-West,
MAE-West, God help you.
They're always overloaded.
And they're gonna add another
30, 50 milliseconds
without breaking a sweat.
So when you can operate
multiple datacenters,
some close to your users,
it helps you.
CDNs like Akamai
are masters of this
and Amazon's FileFront,
a number of others.
What you often do
is what we call edge caching.
Data that doesn't change often,
you throw it all over
the place.
You try to get it
as many places
and as close to as many
people as you can.
So these are some of the reasons
you do want multihoming.
But there are plenty of reasons
you don't want it.
Within a datacenter,
everything's nice, you know?
Every now and then
we talk about it.
It's like being in the womb.
It's warm and comfortable
and you don't have
to go anywhere
and everything's
there for you.
Between machines inside
a datacenter,
you have really high bandwidth.
You have really low latency and
usually that networking cost--
You know, no one charges you
for bandwidth
within a datacenter.
It's generally free.
This is a nice place to be.
All the stuff is more or less
the opposite across datacenters.
Much smaller pipes depending
on which company
you're going with
for backbone connectivity.
Often they're very small.
And you can find bigger ones,
but they cost money.
A lot of money.
Higher latency,
like I was talking about.
A roundtrip between two
separate points,
especially if you're going
across one of those big oceans.
I mean, the Atlantic
and Pacific are big places.
That speed of light getting
across them and back
takes a while.
And finally, like I mentioned,
that network connectivity costs
and it's not cheap.
So if you can help it,
you know,
you don't want a multihome.
Not unless you
absolutely have to.
So--
Sorry, I should
do the wrap-up.
Consistency, transactions,
and now why multihoming?
So, yeah.
This is more of the same.
Like I said,
this a hard problem.
Particularly hard
if you are running,
like I talked about,
a read-write data system
with user data where as soon
as you start accepting writes,
for example,
in more than one location,
you're gonna have inconsistency.
If I try to transfer money
from Alice to Bob over here
and I try to transfer money
from Alice to Eve over here
and Alice doesn't have enough
money for both,
if you let them do that and then
they try to reconcile later,
again, you've created money
or you've given Alice credit
where you probably
didn't mean to.
And so...
maintaining consistency
in the face of that distance
and managing those connections
is not trivial.
So what do we do?
Like I said, often you just want
to avoid this entirely.
And lots of people do.
And this is--
there's a lot
to be said for this.
Solving hard problems
is by definition hard
and the more hard problems
you try to solve,
the less likely you are
to be good at any one of them.
So lots of people just don't
and more power to 'em.
Often the way you do this is
we use the word bunkerizing.
You bring in five sources
of redundant power
and you have four
separate companies
that give you backbone
connectivity
and you have cooling that,
you know,
ranges from massive
water-cooled systems
to ice that you picked up
at the 7-11.
But you pick up
that ice every day
and you pick it up from maybe
two different 7-11s
just so that it's redundant.
So, you know, regardless of what
you're using to cool,
you got something and you got
three others in the back.
You know, bags of ice
in the trunk
just in case your big
water-cooled system goes down.
Lots of people do this.
Microsoft Azure right now
serves out of--
forgotten exactly
what they said.
I believe they only say
North America and not U.S.,
but they right now offer
one U.S. location.
In the future
they will give you the--
Sorry,
one North America location.
In the future,
they will give you the choice
of two North America
locations.
But no help in running
something across them.
Amazon's SimpleDB from what
we know is similar.
I believe there are, you know,
real-time backups.
But unlike most of the other
Amazon web services,
you can't choose
a physical region
or availability zones
for SimpleDB.
I'll get more
into this in a bit.
All the reasons we talked
about for multihoming
are reasons
why you don't want to--
why not multihoming are bad.
One is, if it is a destructive
or somewhat destructive
problem that happens--
fire.
Falling into the ocean
is the example we all use.
Not gonna happen,
but it's very colorful,
so that's always fun.
You could lose data.
You know, we always talk
about backing up
and replicating across disks,
because we know
disks and machines fail.
But sometimes physical
locations fail too.
Fire, hurricane, whatever.
And ideally, you don't want
to lose data,
because the data loss
is pretty much always bad.
I don't know how many
of you noticed
the recent SVColo outage.
SVColo is a datacenter that
is located in Silicon Valley.
Recently had a power outage
for 2, 2 1/2 hours.
People noticed only because
Twitter and FriendFeed
were singly homed in SVColo
and so they're both pretty
popular.
Hands up if you use Twitter.
And, okay, so just out
of curiosity,
hands up if you
use FriendFeed.
All right, okay, good stuff.
The FriendFeed--
One of their co-founders
was the original
product manager on App Engine.
Bret Taylor.
Good guy.
But, you know, poor companies.
They were singly homed.
They were down
for two hours straight.
2 1/2 hours.
They came back up.
They didn't have any data loss.
Thank God.
But they were still down,
you know,
in the middle
of the day for two hours.
No one wants that, you know?
And not their fault.
SVColo should have had some more
redundant power,
but it happens.
Often what happens
is human error
where no matter how much
redundant power
or connectivity you have,
someone presses
the wrong button.
That's the cause
of many outages.
So these kinds of things,
you know,
if you don't multihome,
this is what
you might be in for.
Finally, that geolocation thing
we talked about,
being close to users,
now more than ever,
your users are everywhere
physically.
You know, they're connected,
but connectivity is not flat.
There's a great quote from--
Ah, who is it?
Um.
I forgot.
I think it's one of Tim
Morelli's favorite quotes.
The future is here.
It's just unevenly
distributed.
Connectivity is the same way.
Very unevenly distributed.
So, yeah, if you're
on one datacenter,
everyone's got to get there
and so the people
who are far away,
it's gonna be slow.
The next option is,
you're on multiple datacenters,
but it's similar to MySQL
master-slave replication.
Only one of them
is your master.
The rest you could
sort of read from
for this kind of read-write
database-style data,
but you don't serve
writes from them.
You serve writes from
the one master or datacenter.
This is better,
obviously.
It handles catastrophic
failure better.
You still have your data
in other places.
Since your replicating
asynchronously
in the background...
there will be some window
of data
that was kind of on the wire or
hadn't quite made it
out of the datacenter.
You know, if a datacenter
falls in the ocean,
that small window that hasn't
made it over
to another datacenter
is probably lost.
In reality, doesn't fall
in the ocean.
It just goes offline
for a while.
Comes back up and you get that
window of data back usually.
But it's not available while
the datacenter's down
and if there was something
destructive,
often you've
lost it entirely.
Finally, depending on what kind
of technique you use--
and we'll get into details
in a bit--
the data in your other
datacenters may or may not
be consistent.
They may not be consistent
at all.
It may not be consistent
with regard to
your transactions.
So this is something
to pay attention to
as we get into techniques.
Examples of this.
Amazon has done a good job
of making
physical location
and availability zones,
like, different day centers,
more transparent.
So if you use EC2 or S3,
SimpleQ service,
you can choose where your VMs
and EC2 or your files
in S3 are located
in the U.S. or the E.U.
So you can choose
your master, at least.
EC2 also gives you a choice
of what they call
availability zones,
which are more or less
separate or physically
separated datacenters
within that region.
I actually had to change
this slide recently.
They announced scaling,
load balancing, monitoring.
Stuff that will help you
effectively multihome
across their actually zones,
which is very exciting.
We've been inspired by a lot
of stuff they've done
and so we continue
to get excited
about features like this.
Many financial institutions use
this kind of multihoming.
You hear about credit card
companies with data vaults,
you know,
under six feet of lead.
Underneath--I believe it's
Iron Mountain in Virginia
or a few other locations.
Makes you think of the old days
in the '50s
with bomb shelters.
Kind of a little scary story,
but it's, you know--
it's always fun to go actually
tour one of those sites.
Finally, you get some
geolocation here.
All of your slaves can
serve reads,
depending, again on--
we'll look at the techniques.
Depending on what kind
of consistency
and transaction--
respecting transactions that
you expect.
If you're careful,
your slaves can serve reads
just like, again,
MySQL replication,
which a lot of you who've used
LAMP stacks might have used.
But you still only have
the capacity
of one datacenter
and the geolocation
for writes.
The last option
is the holy grail.
True multihoming.
You have lots of
different datacenters.
They're all serving reads
and writes.
They're all magically
consistent.
They, you know--
transactions just work.
That's really hard.
Really hard.
It's hard--so there are
a number of examples
that do it with just
two datacenters.
One of my favorite stories
here is--
I believe this might
be an urban myth,
but NASDAQ.
There's a story
about how NASDAQ
runs two datacenters
near each other.
Near each other for that whole
speed of light thing.
And they do two-phase commit
across the two datacenters.
So every single trade or every
single transaction
on NASDAQ is guaranteed
to atomically be persistent
to either both or neither.
So the story is
they had to go buy
some networking equipment
at some point.
And they walk in and,
you know,
got their
purchasing manager
and a bunch of engineers come
to do testing
and they're carrying
these suitcases.
They got, like,
five suitcases.
You know, they look heavy and
the networking vendor
looks at 'em and says, "Hey,
you know, what's that for?"
And they open up the suitcases.
They're full of fiber.
And they say, "You know,
our datacenters
"are 27 miles apart.
"This is exactly 27 miles
of fiber.
"Our algorithm, our two-phase
commit thing, works
"if you give us, like, a two
or three-millisecond window.
"So if you can guarantee--
We're gonna hook it up.
"We got this 27 miles
of fiber.
"If you put one of
your routers over here,
"one of 'em over here,
we'll do some measurements.
"If you hit, like,
that two-millisecond window,
"we can do business.
Otherwise, we got to take our
fiber over to the next guy."
So, um...
they do it across two
datacenters and that's hard.
Doing it across multiple
datacenters, more than two,
is fundamentally harder.
On the plus side,
you get all of the benefits.
This does the magic for you.
You handle
catastrophic failure,
expected failure,
you can serve people
from whatever datacenter
was closest to them.
Naturally, if you can
do this at all,
you're gonna pay for it.
Queuing delays, routing delays,
speed of light, all of that.
You got to talk
between datacenters
and it's just fundamentally
slower and a smaller pipe.
So sometimes you might
also pay for it
in capacity or throughput,
but you'll definitely
pay for it in latency.
All right,
so we've got through
the bulk of the background.
Again, talked about consistency
and transactions,
why do you want to multihome,
and what are some of
the kind of broad categories
of multihoming
that you might see.
Let's get into some details.
Like, how do you actually
do this
if you're building
one of these systems.
So this is kind of
the broad outline
for where we're gonna go
in the next 15 minutes.
Down the left side
are things we care about.
This is how we want to evaluate
different techniques
that we're gonna look at.
What kind of consistency
in transactions do we get?
What kind of latency,
throughput?
If something happens,
will we lose any data?
How much data will we lose?
And when we have to failover,
if there is
expected maintenance
or if we need to move things--
Say we're decommissioning
some datacenter,
we need to turn up
another one.
What we call failover,
basically moving some
serving capacity
from one datacenter
to another.
How do we do that?
How well do
the techniques support it?
This is a kind of preview.
The actual techniques
that we're gonna discuss
are across the top.
And I'll get into detail
right now.
Backups,
we all know and love.
We all say you should backup
and, you know,
to varying degrees,
we actually do backup.
You know, our laptops,
our phones, that kind of thing.
Your data as a company or
organization is no different.
You got to backup at minimum.
So this is a sledgehammer.
You know, you make a copy
of all your data.
You got it.
Now you got
to keep it somewhere,
and, you know,
make sure it's stored
and archived for a while
so that it lasts.
But the nice thing is you got
this entire copy.
I said weak consistency here.
It depends.
So some--
depending on how you designed
your system,
if you can backup at
a consistent snapshot
whether you use timestamps
or versioning or whatever,
then you can maintain some
consistency and often
you can maintain
transactions too.
The majority of time, backups
don't work like this.
Mostly you start reading
and copying, you know,
at the beginning
of your data
and you go through
to the end.
It might take a few hours.
It might take a day.
It might take a week.
And so you see an earlier
state at the beginning
than you do at the end.
So if I start reading--
So if I'm transferring money
from "A" to "B"
and I read "A"
and I've backed up "A"
and then someone transfers
that money to "B"
and then I read "B,"
I've lost some of that
transactional consistency
in my backup
and so it takes some thought
to avoid
that kind of problem.
So the other thing
I should have mentioned
is I'm gonna be using the
App Engine datastore again
as a case study here.
Because we evaluated all
of these techniques
for multihoming the datastore
and multihoming App Engine
in general.
We did this with
the datastore.
You know, when we first
dogfooded the App Engine, we--
So we do a lot of what we call
"dogfooding" at Google.
We iterate and make people use
our stuff internally,
often when it's not so good.
And so people get sick
of this at Google.
You're using a ton of stuff
that's very early
and, you know, sometimes it
works, sometimes it doesn't,
but the benefit
is you get to iterate
and you have users constantly
using your stuff
and you can iterate 20,
30, 50 times on something
before you're ready
to launch it.
There's huge value.
Again, it's early and so--
when we first started dogfooding
App Engine internally
at Google,
backups were good enough.
You know, we were okay
with that.
But clearly, it's not good
enough for a production system,
so we need to keep looking.
But as we evaluate, you see
there's a lot of red there.
There's some green too.
Backups are totally offline.
They don't affect how
your storage system works,
so your latency and
your throughput don't change.
Assuming you have good latency
and good throughput,
stays that way.
The rest of it is not so good.
You're gonna lose
all your data
if something happens
since the last backup.
Moving to another datacenter,
you got to backup and restore.
You know, while you do that
move, you're down.
As we talked about,
usually consistency
and transaction support
is weak.
Let's see if we can
do better.
Master-slave replication.
This is basically the same
as what we talked about
primary and hot fail over
a datastore.
Or--sorry.
Datacenters for multihoming.
Again, like we talked about,
MySQL is very commonly used,
but most relational databases
support something like this.
The replication
is asynchronous.
It's in the background,
so it doesn't
affect your online rights.
Which means, like backups,
you generally keep
the throughput and
the latency that you had
before you turned this on.
Generally.
Similar to backups,
the consistency
and transaction support
that you get from this--
If you work hard,
you can get decent support.
but often you're just kind of
sending data as it comes in.
You're just kind of blindly
moving everything over.
And so if you get cut off
halfway through
a transaction
or something like that,
the state of the data that is in
your replica is uncertain.
And so like backups,
you can design it to do better.
But it's non-trivial.
You got to think about
that ahead of time.
So this is actually
what we currently do
with the datastore.
The consistency
and transaction stuff,
we put the time in,
we figured that out.
The catch here is that
with end-user applications,
you can do a lot better.
You can do that whole two-phase
commit thing
or even better and hide it
behind Ajax or whatever,
so that that latency hit
that you're paying for,
your users don't see.
We're offering a much
lower level abstraction.
Honestly, our competition is
as much relational databases
living in the same
datacenter.
Like, one machine over,
right next to you
are your App servers.
As it is, Amazon SimpleDB
or Azure tables
or anything like that.
You know, updates or inserts
into a relational database?
Low milliseconds.
You know, our average write
on App Engine
is already much higher.
You're talking 30, 40
milliseconds.
It's a different model.
Reads in exchange
are often much faster
and we like that trade off,
because on the web
reads outnumber writes vastly.
But the problem
is multihoming--
Truly multihoming
the datastore
as we're gonna see
later down the line,
would add latency.
You would see that latency
doubled if not more,
because you'd have to be paying
for that roundtrip
between datacenters.
So most startups,
most LAMP stacks,
anything that's
singly homed, you know,
is not even quite that good.
So we already feel like there's
a win here for multihoming.
And so the trade off,
we said "Okay."
You know, we're gonna try
to pick the sweet spot
where we give you
almost all the benefits
of multihoming and still
avoid some
of the most egregious costs.
There's a better conclusion
that I'll get to in a bit.
But this is one
of the takeaways.
This is how we multihome
the datastore
across multiple datacenters.
So like we said,
depending on how you--
So...this is actually
not quite fair.
I've given backups
a bad rap compared
to master-slave on consistency
in transactions,
but generally it's harder to do
those with backups.
So I guess that's fair.
Yeah, so if something happens,
you have an almost real-time
copy of data in
your other datacenters.
So you're not gonna lose
nearly as much data,
but you'll a little
in that small window.
And failover,
often you can go read-only
and serve reads from one
of your slave--
your replica datacenters.
But you're not gonna
serve writes
until you have moved
your master
and you know that,
okay, it's in a new datacenter
and no writes
are only going here.
Now I can turn them on.
Multi-master replication
is fascinating.
This has been one of
the most interesting areas
of computer science
for a while now.
It's a lot of fun.
The idea here is that
you support writes
in multiple places
and you find some way
to merge them
at some point later.
So this is similar
asynchronous replication,
but you're serving writes
in multiple locations
and you got to figure out
what to do with them
when there is a collision.
The best you can do here
is eventual consistency,
because writes don't
immediately go everywhere.
We've--
There's a paradigm shift here.
We've assumed
up until this point
that if you have a strong
and consistent system--
master-slave and backup,
we're not affecting
how that system runs.
We're just doing stuff
in the background
to help multihome.
Here we're literally changing
the way the system runs,
because we've got kind
of multiple installations
and they're each serving data
and in the background
they have to reconcile.
The way you do this
in the background--
or the way you do the merging
is you find a way to serialize.
You find a way to impose
an ordering
across all of your writes.
One of the tenets
in distributed systems
is there is no global clock.
At least there
is no global clock you can use.
Things happen in parallel
and you can't really
ever know what happens when
or at least
with regards to each other.
So here we make it up.
You can even have something
that hands out
what we call monotonically
increasing timestamps.
Time stamps that are guaranteed
not to revert.
You can use local timestamps
with skew detection
and other things.
You can use local versions.
So for a given entity, I don't
need to know a global clock.
All I need to know is
for this entity,
what's it's version number.
You can use a distributed
consensus protocol,
which we'll get to
in a bit.
It's kind of putting the cart
before our horse,
but this is the magic
in multi-master.
Merging writes and reconciling
and there are
a number of ways to do it.
Like I said,
since you're serving writes
kind of independently,
there's no way to do
a global transaction.
I mean,
there's no easy way.
You can't offer
a read and a write
in one datacenter
and guarantee that nothing
has happened to it in other
datacenters
that would affect you.
For that, you need
something stronger
that we'll get to
in a bit.
But you have to kind
of accept that this is
kind of like multithreading
where you
don't even have locks.
Your locks are all in
the background after the fact.
You do what you're gonna do.
Someone else does
what they're gonna do.
You figure it out afterward.
The result of that is
one of things
we care strongly in
the App Engine datastore
is strong consistency.
We feel like this is a key
differentiating factor
from systems like SimpleDB,
which there are
a lot of nice properties
when you go eventually
consistent.
But using it to build
an application,
using it as infrastructure,
it's just a lot harder.
That mental model of
I do something
and I don't know
when it's reflected,
when it's visible.
It's a lot harder to use.
So we didn't really
consider this much
for the App Engine datastore
because it would have
been harder to provide
strong consistency.
We started with that.
The last thing we want
to do is take it away
from you, you know?
So what do the trade-offs
look like
for multi-master replication?
We lost some
transaction support.
But in exchange,
we don't have to go read-only
for failover.
Every datacenter is doing
writes on its own,
serving both reads and writes.
And so if you have
to move one
or take one down,
the others can still
handle the writes.
So it's a trade-off.
two-phase commit.
This what I started
to talk about with NASDAQ
and many of you might be
familiar with this
if you have
database backgrounds.
So this is a protocol
for doing transactions
across separate systems
or at least
separate shards
of the database--
that kind of thing--
where's there's no single
master that everything
goes through.
I call this semi-distributed
because there is always
a master or coordinator
for a given two phase
commit transaction.
You have to pick one of them.
Usually you impose
a total ordering
at the beginning
of all your nodes
and so that you know
for any set of nodes
who is the master.
Oh, it's the one
with the lowest I.D.
Or, you know--
or you just ask someone.
hey say, "Oh, this is
the master out of this set."
That works when you have very
broadly sharded data
or highly sharded data.
So in App Engine we have
this concept of entity groups
where every entity is in
an entity group
and we say each entity group
should be roughly
the size of a user's data,
more or less.
You know, one of our large
applications,
BuddyPoke,
has 40 million users.
Or last they reported,
it had 40 million users.
And so that's 40 million
different shards
and different possible nodes
to participate
in two-phase commit.
If you did that
in that setting, saying,
"Okay, there's one master per
two-phase commit transaction,"
that's not such a big deal,
'cause you got 40 million
to choose from
and any transaction's only gonna
use a few of them.
With datacenters, you don't
have 40 million datacenters.
You usually have, like,
three.
Maybe five, maybe ten if
you're really big,
but it's--what?
Do some math, you know?
10, 12 orders
of magnitude difference.
What you're gonna find
is that
if you two-phase commit often,
one or a small subset
of your datacenters tends
to be the master
depending on how many
participate in each transaction.
So it's only semi-distributed
in that sense.
You're often going through
the same masters.
What else do I want
to say about two-phase commit?
Because of that it's so--
oh, yeah.
So the next interesting thing
about two-phase commit
is it's synchronous.
For a given master, all two
phase commit transactions
are serialized through
that master,
which kind of kills
your throughput.
Also hurts your latency.
There's a variant called
three phase commit,
which lets you do a sync,
but it doesn't
get rid of that
per-transaction master.
Yeah, so we care about data--
write throughput
in the datastore and so
like multi-master,
we never seriously
considered this.
Yeah, we want--
scaling is important to us.
And any single or semi-single
point of failure
or serialization point is just
not gonna fly with us, so.
But on the plus side,
it works.
This is the first kind
of truly--
true multihoming technique
that we have seen
where you can transactionally
atomically
write something to either two
datacenters or none
and that's really powerful.
NASDAQ clearly thought so.
So again, this is kind of--
this is the biggest paradigm
shift we're gonna see.
Up until here we have seen
kind of offline background
asynchronous replication
and reconciling.
This is the first technique
we've seen
that does synchronous,
like, online.
It'll report back
to the user on a put
or insert or update "yes"
in both datacenters
or "No, it hit
neither of them."
As you can see that in the
colors it's the opposite, right?
Out of the box,
you get strong consistency.
You get full
transaction support.
If any one datacenter falls
in the ocean, doesn't matter.
You know everything
that mattered.
Everything that you reported
success on
is in the other one.
Same with failover.
Generally you need
what we call
"at least 'n' + one."
So if you're serving
out of "n" datacenters,
you need at least one more...
so that whenever you need
to take one down temporarily
to do maintenance
or to move things,
you've still got that "n" for
the duration.
You pay for it with latency
and throughput, as I mentioned.
The last thing
we're gonna look at
is what's called Paxos.
And I'm sure people in
the audience can correct me.
I believe it was--
was it Leslie Lamport
or Bruce--
I think it was Leslie Lamport.
If anyone knows different,
yell out.
But he wrote this
great paper about--
I believe it was philosophers
on a Greek island,
the island of Paxos.
And it was totally esoteric
and obscure
and you read the paper
and it was a fun story
and at the end you had no idea
what he was proposing,
but you knew he was on
to something big.
I've read the paper.
I don't pretend
to understand it.
I learned Paxos from other
people at Google
who are much smarter than me.
And even then it's non-trivial,
but it works.
So like two-phase commit,
Paxos is a, what we call,
consensus protocol.
You have a group
of independent nodes
and you want
to reach consensus
on at least a majority
of them
if not all of them
on something.
Unlike two-phase commit,
Paxos is fully distributed.
There is no single master
for any given transaction.
Again, as I put the slide up,
everyone reads first
and then turns back
and listens
and so you've
already read the joke.
But the joke here is that
a really smart guy at Google
named Mike Burrows
says every consensus
protocol out there
or every fully distributed
consensus protocol
is either Paxos or Paxos
with cruft or broken.
And I don't think he's been
proven wrong yet.
And so, you know,
I'm not gonna be the one
to bet against him.
Like I said, the actual
protocol--the Paxos protocol--
is similar
to two-phase commit,
which I didn't even really
talk through.
There is a propose--
there is a propose step
and then, basically,
a grieve step
or a notify step.
Similar to two-phase commit
with the difference
that you only need a majority.
You don't need the master
running things.
So as long as a majority
of your nodes
that are participating
in Paxos
or a majority of your
datacenters come back and say,
"Yes, I agree.
We are here now.
We're at this position
in the log."
Or, "Yes, I agree.
This has been persistent,"
then you're good.
Like I said, underneath,
similar to phase commit.
The nice thing is there is
less of a--
less serialization.
It's distributed,
but it can also--
you can run multiple
Paxos around
multiple Paxos transactions
in parallel.
It's not serialized on whatever,
you know--per datacenter.
You're not gonna have this
serial pipe
that every two phase transaction
is going to go through
one at a time, which gives
you better throughput.
The problem here--
and I didn't quite get into
enough with two-phase commit,
so if we look at it we saw this
huge drop in latency
in two-phase commit.
The reason there is, again,
you're doing everything online.
You're waiting
for those roundtrips.
It's actually two roundtrips
between datacenters
before you can go back
to the user and say,
"Yes, your write went in."
This is where you see
writes, you know--
100, 150 depending on how far
your datacenters are away
and how many are participating.
200, 250 milliseconds,
which is a long time.
And so you see that
with Paxos too.
Still highly--
you can't avoid that.
If you want true multihoming,
you're gonna pay for it.
We really wanted to do this
for the App Engine datastore.
It's just the right thing
for so many reasons
and we use it in so many other
parts of Google.
We really wanted to.
We couldn't quite get
it to work
with the latency guarantees
that we needed to pass on.
Or not guarantees.
But we couldn't in all
honesty tell you all,
"Writes right now are
30, 40, 50 milliseconds.
"They're gonna be 150.
Just trust us that it's better.
Just trust us."
It wouldn't quite fly.
Now we can describe exactly why
for reasons like this.
But confiding against,
you know,
five millisecond updates
and inserts in databases?
That's a tough battle to win.
We tried some variations.
We tried physically
close together
just like NASDAQ
with those 27 miles.
It helped a little,
but you can't avoid
the fact that
you're doing two roundtrips
across lots of routers
and queues in between--
routing and queuing delays
in between.
We even tried putting two nodes
in the same datacenter,
which would give you a weaker,
you know--
a weaker set of guarantees,
but at least those roundtrips
are within a datacenter.
And even then,
it's not great.
You still have to hit at least
some of the other nodes.
What we can do is let
you opt in
to something like Paxos
and I'll talk more
about this later.
Having said that, we use Paxos
a ton in App Engine.
It's used in a lock server
that Google uses very heavily.
And we use that in App Engine
usually via the lock server,
but some on our own
for coordinating
anything that we do
across datacenters.
Particularly anything where
we move state.
If your app is serving
in one place
and we need to move it
to serve in another place,
we coordinate that with Paxos.
Memcache.
Memcache has interesting
multihoming of its own.
In coordinating and managing
that, we use Paxos.
Offline processing
is the same thing.
You'll hear more about
offline processing
tomorrow at 10:45.
I encourage you,
if there's one App Engine talk
you go to,
don't make it this one,
but too late.
The one this morning
from Alon Levi
which describes
how App Engine works was great,
but the offline processing one
tomorrow at 10:45,
we're excited about that.
We're looking for you all to try
it out, so check that out.
That uses Paxos
under the hood too.
So this is the final diagram.
The kind of final evaluation.
You'll see that
the only change like
I talked about between Paxos
and two-phase commit
is that you get
better throughput.
The really sad thing here,
the part that makes me,
you know, cry into my pillow
at night--
and I'm only half-joking--
there's no fully green bar.
You can't find anything on that
diagram that makes you happy.
That gets everything even--
That gets everything right.
It's disappointing.
It makes me sad.
And so we picked one that
had green and yellow.
Life is trade-offs.
It's no fun,
but it's a fact of life.
Conclusion, again,
no silver bullet.
There is no--
There is no vertical
green slice.
You still got
to do it though.
That two-hour outage
in SVColo?
That's just unacceptable.
Much less if there was
something destructive
and you actually lost data.
It's fundamentally unacceptable.
It's just not okay.
The other trade-off that
I'm looking forward
to talking more about
eventually is, again,
that this is inherently
a trade-off.
Some apps need one thing.
Some apps need another.
We're a platform and we're
a pretty high-level platform,
but honestly, we don't know
what's right for you.
You know what's right for you.
If you're a bank,
you want Paxos.
You want two-phase commit
across maybe
two or more datacenters.
If you are some, you know--
if you're a game,
you don't really care.
You just want fast responses.
And so what we'd like
to do in the future
is offer--
give you the option.
So, okay, if you want what
we call strong writes,
if you want two-phase commit
or Paxos across datacenters,
you can do it.
Just tell us on
a per-write basis
or maybe on
per-entity group basis.
On the other hand,
if you want fast writes
and highly available writes,
if you want to read from one
of those replica datacenters
and you are okay with
giving up the guarantee
that it's always
strongly consistent,
maybe 1 in 100 times
you'll get stale data
because the update
that you just did
hadn't made it to
that datacenter yet.
Tell us on a per-write basis,
you know, and we can do that.
Or hopefully in the future.
We talk about this a lot
internally at Google
where there's
no one size fits all.
And so we want
to embrace that.
We, you know,
do that internally.
And, you know, App Engine
is infrastructure
like anything else.
We want to let you all choose.
That's it.
I've taken much more time
than I expected.
So feel free to come up
to the mics and ask questions
and I'm gonna go to Moderator
and answer
a few questions there too.
Let's see if there's
anything there.
Ah, perfect.
So I'll trade off.
"What is Google going to do
about providing storage
"as discussed a bit
in the keynote this morning?
Is Google going to attempt
to compete with S3, et cetera?"
Good question.
So we do plan to offer more
options for storing
blob data in App Engine.
Particularly blob data larger
than one megabyte,
because that's the limit
in the datastore right now.
I don't have any particular
announcements,
but we are working on that.
And we're excited about that.
I tend to kind of live
in the App Engine bubble
and so, I mean, I pay attention
to the other stuff,
but I'm only authoritative
on App Engine.
man: Could you talk a little bit
about entity groups
megastore and how
that would apply
in your cross-datacenter
replication models?
Barrett: Sure.
So entity groups
are how we shard
or partition data
in App Engine.
All writes and transactions
go through journals
or logs at
the entity group level.
And so within an entity group,
all writes and transactions
are serialized.
That is our unit
of consistency.
And so under the hood,
a lot of the replication
and data management we do is via
those logs per entity group.
So if we were to use
multi-master replication
or right now we can do
master-slave replication--
When we replicate,
it's at the level
of basically a log commit.
So whether that was
a single entity write
or a batch write that wrote
multiple entities
to an entity group
or a transaction,
that log contains
basically the DIF.
all of the changes.
And so what we're
gonna be replicating is,
as a unit, that log for each
commit to an entity group.
And so that's how we maintain
both strong consis--
or we maintain consistency
across replication
and also how we maintain
transactions so that
at any time we can
go look at the state
of one of those
replica datacenters
and it would be consistent
with regards to its--
well, consistent
with regard to transactions.
"If I put a lot of data
in the datastore,
what options do I have
for backing it up?"
We would--
it's a good question.
So...
If you want to ensure against
failures of datacenters,
you know, catastrophic
failures like the ones
we were talking about,
we would hope
that we would
do the right thing
such that you don't need to.
In reality, like I said,
much error--
You know, much of error
is human error.
And so, you know,
sometimes you might upload
something that
has a bug in your code
or anything else.
And so you definitely
want a backup for that.
This is all background.
The answer is we have tools
for doing
high throughput,
bulk upload, and download.
And those are shipped
with the STK
and the STK is open source,
so I would--
Right now I would
say bulk upload
and download
are the way to go.
man: Hi.
So a couple questions.
The first one
is around use cases.
Do you imagine a use case where,
you know,
I'm an enterprise and my data
is critical to me
and that my application
is running on App Engine
and I sync up with you
and you cache the data
and the application
can actually run and scale,
but my data is still
kept locally.
What kind of use cases?
And the second question is--
Barrett: Sorry, do you mind if
I take 'em one at a time?
So you're saying
you would write an app,
like, an App Engine app,
that accesses
your on-premises data
or you're saying
you would synchronize
your on-premises data--
man: So I'm worried
about having my data
at Google completely,
all right?
Barrett: Okay.
man: I want the data
in my enterprise
but running my app on yours.
But are you thinking
of other use cases,
because you didn't start
with that, you know?
Sort of thinking multihoming--
Since you're shielding
a lot with the platform,
I don't have control over
where the data goes.
Barrett: Absolutely.
So there are a couple
questions here.
man: That was my second
question.
Barrett: Okay, sure.
Got it.
One is if you
have data right now
and you want to use App Engine
but you don't
want to give up all your control
over that data,
you want to keep
it on-premises
or at least keep a copy
of it on-premise.
You can use these bulk upload
and download tools
to basically synchronize
your data,
and there are actually people
who have written
better tools to let you
basically upload
and download DIFs.
So just the delta
of what happened
since you last synchronized.
You could even write something
that synchronizes online
using HTTP APIs that you access
via URLFetch.
Something like that.
I wouldn't recommend it.
I've worked on a number
of systems where you try
to synchronize data
in multiple places
and it's just inevitably
difficult and error prone
and it bites you in the ass
every time and no fun.
You can do it.
Honestly, I would
recommend against it.
The second question
is more interesting.
Can you choose physically where
your app serves
or where your data lives?
Which is a great question.
This came up actually this
morning at Alon Levi's talk.
So there are regulations
like the E.U.'s safe harbor
data regulations,
which require that data
is stored inside the E.U.
Which is honestly one of--
I believe one of
the main reasons that Amazon
started offering a choice.
You know, you can have
your S3 data.
Live in the U.S.
or live in E.U.
We want to do that too.
I don't have any specific
announcements
or a timeline,
but we hear you.
We totally understand this is
just a fundamental requirement
and we need to do it.
man: Wouldn't that imply
that now I have
fine-grained control over where
my data goes?
So in other words, it breaks
your shielding from the platform
and scaling for me.
Because now I have to tell you
I have to make some decisions.
Barrett: That would give you
some control,
but the techniques
we're talking about here
don't care about physically
where your data is,
so we would--
all of the things that we--
the invariance we want
to maintain
to make sure your data
is safe,
like a number of replicas,
a number of physical
locations.
We would expect
to maintain those
regardless of physical
location.
What we'll be giving you
is a choice some--
a choice and a way
to ensure some guarantees
such that make sure all copies
of my data are in the E.U.,
for example.
We want to do that.
I don't have details
on how it would work.
Honestly, we don't entirely
know yet, but we want to.
man: Okay, thanks.
Barrett: Yeah.
Let me take one more and then
I'll close it down.
"Can you explain
what an entity group is
with respect to how datastore
transactions work?"
I think I did that before,
so I'm actually
gonna call that.
"Which technique is
the Google datastore using?"
We are using
master-slave replication
across datacenters.
The main reason is latency.
It gives us the best guarantees
that we can get
without making every
datastore write take
under 200 milliseconds.
And this is a key takeaway.
I should have been clearer
about this.
It's definitely one thing
I'm telling you right now.
I'm gonna let you all go
if there are no more questions.
I can answer the rest
of these offline.
But thank you for coming.
I appreciate it.
Have a good conference.
[applause]